BENCH FOR THE ISLANDERS.
HE LOST ONE GAME DUE TO THE
DEATH OFF
A THREAT.
>> Brendan: FLYERS WERE 0 FOR 1
.
VAN RIEMSDYK INSTEAD.
PAGEAU CHIPPED ITISLANDERS.
HE DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGHTHE RE
BARZAL.
>> Butch: BELLOWS WAS COMING
LATE.
JUST NEEDED ANOTHER .
>> Butch: GOOD CHIP BY PAGEAU,
ANDO TURN BUND MINI,
BUND MINUTHE BARZAL LINE
FINALLY GOT IT GOING, HAD A
LITTLE OFFENSIVE ZONE TIME IN  .
FUNNELING THE PUCK INOCCER
PROGRAM AT MALLOY COLLEGE.
TO BE DOWN A MAN A COUPLE OF
TIMESOPPORTUNITY.
BEAUTIFUL ACROSS-ICE PASS.
LOOK AT THE BLOCKER.
HE KEE HERE TO START THE
SECOND PERIOD.
SOROKIN I GUESS WAS RISTOLAINEN
THERE AS BACKUP.
STOPPED IT FOR A MOMENT.
A CHANCE FOR LAUGHTON.
>> A.J.: CHANCES AT BOTH ENDS OF
THE ICE.
THE FLYERS HAD TWO OF THEIR BEST
OPPORTUNITIES WHILE THEY WERE A
WITH LINDBLOM,BACK, THE TWO NON.
WHATOR NELSON.
NELSON GRABS H THE HESITATION.
CLUTTERBUCK PLAYING THE ANGLE TO
SALLOW.
SALLOW HAS GREENE
LOOKING, LOOK, NOTHING, NOTHING,
LITTLE FAKE.
DOWN INTO THE AND
FWARBY. UPN
THREE GAMES.
IT HAS BEEN AN VERY INTERESTING
GAME,
NELSON TRIES TO GET TO THE NET.
HE DRAW ASPEN AT, AON, HE JUST
WON'T GIVE UP ON IT.
WAHLSTROM IS THERE.
AND A>> Brendan: PARISE BATTLIN
FRONT WITH SA GAME.
>> Butch: HE HAS BEEN ONFTER
THIS ONE.
YANDLE BACK.
PAGEAU WITH SPEED.
TO HIM.
ATKINSON THIS TIME FOR.
GLOVES IT DOWN.
IN THE EMPTY NET.
HE GOT IT.
ON THE SAME NIGHT CASEY CIZIKAS
HE WAS READY TO GO.
I MOON, HE HAS BEEN SO